Yes, Amazon's "The Rings of Power"
takes place thousands of years before
"The Hobbit" and "The Lord of the Rings." But
to immortal beings, what's a few millennia?
"The Rings of Power" actor Robert
Aramayo said of his character Elrond,
"When I read about him, I'm always
really interested in the way that
Tolkien talks about [how Elrond
is] counted amongst the immortals,
which is an interesting thing. Counted, it
doesn't necessarily say that he is one."
Biologically speaking, Elrond is definitely
immortal. But he's also related to mortal Men,
immortal Elves, and even the angelic
Maiar. Elrond's critical role as
the bridge between many of Middle-earth's
peoples, combined with his eternal nature,
keeps him in the spotlight for a very long time.
"I was there the day the strength of men failed."
In "The Rings of Power," he's a scrappy
young politician. By the time we see him
in "The Hobbit" films, he's the leader of
Rivendell and a member of the White Council.
He continues in that capacity in "The Lord of
the Rings," helping point characters including
Frodo and Aragorn in the right direction. By the
end of that story, he does leave Middle-earth for
a quiet retirement in the Blessed Realm in the
West. By that point, he's more than earned it.
Over the years, Tolkien struggled with Galadriel's
role in Middle-earth. He wrote his way through it,
it seems. The book "Unfinished Tales" has
an entire section titled "The History of
Galadriel and Celeborn [KELL-uh-born]." While
full of interesting facts and parts of stories,
the text contradicts itself and presents
multiple versions of the heroine's role.
One thing that's clear is that Tolkien
wanted Galadriel to play an essential
role in the Second Age, and the "The Rings
of Power" showrunners have used that as an
opportunity to make her essentially the series
lead, at least so far. Galadriel was also a
founding member of the White Council during
the Third Age. This allowed Peter Jackson to
insert her into "The Hobbit" films when that
group takes down the Necromancer in Mirkwood.
And the Lady of Lorien plays an
essential role in "The Lord of
the Rings," hosting and helping the
Fellowship on their way to Mordor.
"I will diminish, and go into
the West, and remain Galadriel."
In Peter Jackson's adaptation of "The Lord
of the Rings," the Dark Lord Sauron's eye
sits perched atop his massive tower
of Barad-dûr in the Land of Shadow,
scanning the countryside for any sign of trouble.
Sauron also appears in "The
Hobbit" trilogy of films,
this time in the form of the Necromancer.
Originally a minor character, Jackson took
Sauron's foreboding presence and inserted it as a
major plot point in his own version of that story.
Sauron's presence is likewise felt from
the beginning of "The Rings of Power."
He's briefly in the prologue for the first
episode. Then his sigil starts showing up
everywhere, and he's even named multiple
times. When he does finally reveal himself,
it will likely be in his more attractive
form as Annatar, the Lord of Gifts.
There's one more character in the movies and
the show: Gil-galad has a brief cameo at the
beginning of "The Fellowship of the Ring"
and is already in Prime Video's series.
Besides that small role and the three big ones,
no one else from Peter Jackson's films is
confirmed for "The Rings of Power" as of now.
But a few other names could join
that list as the story plays out.
First off, there's Gandalf. Fans have been
debating who the man in the fire could be
since he first appeared in the marketing.
While that mystery hasn't been solved in the
early episodes, it's clear that the show
could be working Gandalf into the story.
Legolas is another. Since the adventuring
elf's backstory is relatively vague,
there's a chance that we
could see the character pop
up in "The Rings of Power." Jackson found a
way to fit him into "The Hobbit," after all.
Some other possibilities include Thranduil,
who was the king of Mirkwood long before he
appeared in "The Hobbit." There's also Treebeard.
We know that the new series will have Ents, and,
according to the lore, Treebeard
was their leader at that time.
"It takes a long time to
say anything in old Entish."